وينضم الينا مره اخرى من اوهايو
البروفيسور جون كوجلي استاذ القانون
الدولي في جامعه اوهايو وكنت اسالك عن
القانون الدولي
وموقفه من هذا القصف العشوائي الوحشي
المستمر الذي اودا بحياه قرابه ال 5000
مدني اغلبهم من النساء والاطفال في غزه
دون ان يقدم الجانب الاسرائيلي دليلا
واحدا على انه استهدف اي هدف عسكري
نعم القانون الدولي لا يسمح الا
باستهداف الاهداف
العسكريه ونحن نرى الان بان هناك عدد كبير
من الضحايا المدنيه والان اسرائيل لم تكن
حريصه
بالقدر المطلوب والضروري لحمايه المدنيين
وايضا البناء التحتيه المدنيه نرى الهجوم
الذي حدث في مخيم جبالي على سبيل المثال
لكن هناك العديد من الامثله على
امتداد غزه ينبغي حمايه المدنيين
و مساله اختار السكان في شمال غزه
بضروره اخلا المكان وان اي شخص يبقى هناك
فهو
يعتبر تابع لحماس فهذا شيء
غير مقنع
وهذا يقول طبعا من وجهه ال نظر
الاسرائيليه ان اي شخص يبقى هناك هو هدف
مشروع بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي بغض النظر
ان كان عنصر من حماس لكن هذا شيء ممنوع
قطعا من جانب من وجهه نظر القانون الدولي
طبعا هو ممنوع ومخالف للقانون الدولي لكن
نحن لا نتحدث عن مخالفات هنا نحن نتحدث عن
جرائم البعض قال انها تصل الى حد جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه لانه
حينما تضع اسوارا حول عدد من الناس في
منطقه محدوده بشكل يشبه معسكرات التصفيه
النزيه فنحن نتحدث عن اباده جماعيه وتمنى
عنهم الدواء والغذاء والماء والكهرباء
والوقود وتحصر جوا وبرا و
بحرا ما هو التوصيف الحقيقي لما يجري في
غزه من حصار وقتل بهذه
الطريقه نعم هذه جرائم حرب بشكل واضح تقع
مسؤوليتها على حكومه غزه
وعلى مسؤوليه ايضا اصحاب القرار الذين
يقومون باداره العمليات العسكريه في
المرحله الراهنه بالنسبه لي يمكن ان نصف
ما يحدث ايضا
باباده الجماعيه
وم المحظور في حاله الحرب قدل الناس بهذه
الطريقه الممنهجه ومن المحظور جدا ايضا
خلق اوضاع انسانيه مزريه تقوم بالاضرار
بالمدنيين وما يحدث الان واباده جماعيه
نتحدث عن منطقه شمال غزه وايضا في مناطق
اخرى في قطاع غزه
والظروف
الموجوده الان لا تسمح كي تكون هناك حياه
عاديه بالنسبه للمدنيين هناك استهداف
للمدنيين والبنى التحتيه
المدنيه هذه جريمه اباده جماعيه كما
تفضلت ما
عقابها
العقوبه بالنسبه للاباده الجماعيه هناك
امكانيه لفتح التحقيق ومتابعه امام
المحكمه الدوليه
ويمكن سجن المسؤول عن هذه الاباده
الجماعيه مدى الحياه اذا ما ثبتت
الادانه وكيف يمكن الوصول للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لانه
كما يقال بالمثل العربي المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه يعني اذن من طين واخرى من عجين
وكان ما يجري في غزه لا يعنيها كيف يمكن
ان تصل الامور الى ان تحقق فيها المحكمه
الجنايات
الدوليه نعم هذا صحيح للاسف المحكمه
الجنائيه
الدوليه لا تنظر فيما يحدث في غزه على
انه شيء خطير او وصل الى مستويات متقدمه
من الخطره للغايه
الان ينبغي ان يتم تفعيل عمل هذه المحكمه
ينبغي ان تتاح لها الامكانيه للقيام
بمتابعه
حقيقيه اولئك الذين يقومون بهذه
الجرائم
واعتقد ان حكومه فلسطين بامكانها ان تاخذ
الامام المبادره
وترفع الدعوه على اسرائيل امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وذلك تحت ظل
مقتضيات التي تقوم ب فح متابعات ضد اوليك
الذين يقومون ب
التطهير العرقي او الاباده
الجماعيه وفي هذه الحاله من الاشخاص
المرشحون لان توجه لهم هذه
التهمه طبعا اي شخص واي من
المسؤولين الذين يقفون وراء هذه الافعال
وهذه ال
ضد المدنين تحدث هنا عن اولئك الذين
يامرون
ب قصف بعميه القصف واستهداف المدنيين
والبنا التحتيه المدنيه ل اي من المسؤولين
اي من القيادات
الاسرائيليه هي مسؤوله امام محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه عن هذا التطهير العرقي
وهذه هي الماساه التي تحدث في غزه هل هل
بوسع السلطه الفلسطينيه صحيح هي
موقعه لكن هي ليست دوله لا
يعتبرها لا تعتبرها كثير من من الدول ليست
لها صفه الدوله هل بوسعها ان ترفع هذه
الدعوه بصفتها الحاليه وهل يجوز لاي دوله
عربيه او معنيه في العالم ان تتقدم بمثل
هذه
الدعوه يس
نعم هذا صحيح
حكومه السلطه الفلسطينيه لديها القدره
القانونيه والصلاحيه القانونيه لرفع قضيه
ضد اسرائيل بالنظر الى ما يحدث من اباده
جماعيه وهذا امر واضح من قبل المحكمه
الجنايه قبل سنوات قبل فتره فلسطين قامت ب
رفع قضيه ضد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عندما تم تحويل السفاره الى الامريكيه الى
القدس
واعتقد ان فلسطين لديها القدره للقيام
بهذا الامر وما هي واجبات المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه حيال وصول هذه الدعاوه
اليه لان هنالك دعاوه كما تفضلت من الجانب
الفلسطيني سواء ب مساله نقل السفاره او
سواء حتى بمقتل الصحفيين ملف الصحفيين 50
صحفي قتلوا قتلهم الاحتلال وقدم ذلك
لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه ولم تدلي حتى
بتعليق عليه ما هي واجبات المحكمه اذا رفع
الفلسطينيون او اي دوله معنيه قضايا تتعلق
بما يجري حاليا في
فلسطين
نعم اذا هناك قضيه ترفع ضد اسرائيل من قبل
الحكومه الفلسطينيه حكومه السلطه
الفلسطينيه
فهذه القضيه ستندرج تحت اطار الاباده
الجماعيه وينبغي النظر في هذه القضيه بعض
اسابيع وينبغي الاشاره الى الادله
الضروريه لهذه الاباده الجماعيه دعوه
لاسرائيل تتوقف عن هذه الاباده اذا هذه هي
التزامات
ال المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه واذا ما تم
اطلاق هذه المسطره فعلى المدعي العام ان
يحقق في
هذه المساله بل هناك ايضا امكانيه للتحقيق
من قبل المحكمه في هذه الجريمه حتى من دون
رفع قضيه من اي جهه كانت ا مسؤوليات
المحكمه الجنا
واضحه وينبغي ان يكون هناك تحقيق ومن ثم
ادانه لمسؤولين اسرائيليين يقفون وراء هذه
الاعمال طبعا كما قالت الامم المتحده في
تغريده انه حتى في الحروب هنالك قواعد كيف
يمكن حمايه المدنيين في
غزه وما هي واجبات الدوله المحتله لانه
المحتل مسؤول مسؤوليه مباشره عن حياه
المدنيين تحت الاحتلال وحتى هذه اللحظه
غزه تحت الاحتلال لانه مسيطر على برها
ومائها
وحدودها واجوائها وقصف مطارها وقصف
مينائها ما واجبات دوله الاحتلال ازاء
الشعوب المحتله في مثل هذه
الصراعات نعم كما يعلم الجميع اسرائيل هي
القوه المحتله لغزه
وهناك قانون دولي بالتاكيد
في هذا الخصوص وهذه الدول المحتله ينبغي
لها ان تضمن حقوق الناس حقوق المواطنين
وعليها ان
تحمي السكان المدنيين ل تلك المنطقه
المحتله وهذا واضح حسب القانون الدولي
وحسب اتفاقيات
الدوليه تعود القرن الماضي هناك ايضا
التزامات تعود
لاتفاقيه
جنيف ل
1944 حسب الماده
وهه الماده تقول بان لا ينبغي ان يكون
هناك او تكون هناك عقوبه جماعيه في هذه
الاماكن وهناك ايضا اتفاقيه وملحق
لاتفاقيه جنيف لعام
1949 ونفسها تؤكد ايضا على نفس
المساله ايضا من ضمن القضايا المطروحه هو
قضيه حق وواجب الشعوب الخاضعه للاحتلال ان
تقاوم هذا
الاحتلال وهذا الاحتلال الذي نتحدث عنه هو
احتلال استيطاني احلالي يعني ليس مجرد
وجود قوات في ارض الارض المحتله وانما
وجود مستوطنين يستولون على هذه الارض الا
يعد هذا عملا عدائيا الاستيطان الا يعد
عملا عدائيا في القانون
الدولي نعم نعم هذا صحيح هذه اعمال عدائيه
في نظر القانون الدولي اسرائيل تقوم
باعمال عدائيه من خلال الاستلاء على الارض
والاستيطان وما الى ذلك عندما يدخل جيش
معين الى ارض تعود لشعب اخر فبالتاكيد
الشعب المحتل لديه حق في
المقاومه
وبامكانه ان يتخذ خطوات عسكريه من اجل
تحرير
ارضه كلام مثير لانتباه فعلا نشكر شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المعلومات السيد البروفيسور
جون كويي استاذ القانون الدولي في جامعه
اوهايو عن حق الشعوب المحتله في مقاومه
المحتل وسميت الاشياء بمسمياتها سميت ما
يجري بالعباده الجماعيه وسميت الاستيطان
بالعدوان فانا اشكرك على ذلك ونواصل معكم